oder was geht ab hier soll max und ihr
habt mir ganz offen die kommentar
geschrieben
die lappen du kannst überhaupt kein sg
mehr und ich werde jetzt probieren ob
das stimmt in dem ich ein paar brötchen
qsc spiele ich befürchte dass ich
tatsächlich kein sg mehr kann irgendwie
in letzter zeit ich spiele halt nur noch
diese ganzen schilling geschichten wie
get also wo man halt wenn man am anfang
gut ist ordentlich was kompensieren kann
sage ich mal so ein pvp skills und in
letzter zeit habe ich das gefühl dass
ich ja vielleicht ein bisschen
schlechter geworden bin und das war
jetzt eine kleine bestandsaufnahme sein
dieses video bin ich schlecht muss ich
vielleicht ein ausführliches training
anlegen weil hoops ware und sowas gibts
ja auch noch dieses jahr nicht mehr
natürlich dürften ja die meisten
mitbekommen haben aber es wird es
definitiv noch und der kläger hat
eindeutig zu viele pfeile habe ich das
gefühl so ich habe leider keinen bogen
sonst könnte ich den irgendwie boxen
aber ich habe gedacht die spiel jetzt
einfach mal eine runde solo qsc eine
runde team usd und dann dürfte das
deshalb nicht kommen
meist den habe ich aber vor allem wenn
auch mit ein bisschen glück bisher habe
ich relativ glück diese muss ich sagen
ich weiß nicht gefällt euch das
überhaupt wollt ihr euch hier einziehen
es grenzen gibt es natürlich schon
länger und ist nicht mehr so wirklich
special
aber dadurch dass es in letzter zeit
nicht mehr so viele bringen also ist es
eigentlich schaut einfach darauf was
mache ich schlecht was kann ich besser
machen und sollte ich überhaupt noch pvp
spielen aber eigentlich finde es
einigermaßen okay dass das viel glück
ich glaube diese habe ich vor allem
glück wer jetzt nicht sagen dass ich gut
bin weil in letzter zeit wirklich wer
diesem video was ich damit es geht schon
mit meinem bruder aufgenommen habe
da habe ich echt davor vor allem wir
haben irgendwie und versuche gehabt und
ich habe jedes mal gefehlt und sowas
und deshalb habe ich mir so ein bisschen
gedanken gemacht als dann jeder in die
kommentare schreiben
du kannst überhaupt nichts mehr was soll
der kag und mal schauen vielleicht noch
kriegen bevor ich kam zumindest fire
eindrücken kenntnis so da ist ja der da
vorne
der kann sich nicht von mir verstecken
mein freund der mein freund okay aber
schon wieder kaffee aber es ist nicht so
schlimm
fertig mit gesehen hätte geben können
wenn du wenn du ran kommen willst dann
kommen als sondern komme einfach an
ok
jetzt kommt er natürlich näher gut ist
bonn 8 ist vom ds gestorben die
bionische lief jetzt die tatsächliche
herausforderung kann ich in einer runde
tsg überleben und kann ich meine
stimmung noch tiefer stellen
ich weiß es nicht ich komme mir vor wie
so ein werbe sprecher ich glaube die
haben auch kein schönes leben wenn ihr
jetzt mal ihre stimme zu tode steve
stellen müssen
ich habe auch ich hab schon wieder glück
freunde klappt das glücklich einfach mit
mir das glück will dass ich okay das ist
schon mal kein team das sie angst dass
der typ von hinten jetzt kommt ich will
dir am meisten habe ich so so so so so
einigermaßen sortiert und bisher waren
auch teams getrennt also ich bin
eigentlich zufrieden und dafür dass ich
nicht eingespielt bin dass die zweite
runde minecraft ich werde spielen ich
habe bei dem von abgenommen klebt das
ist jetzt ein problem sage ich erst mal
und kassierte am ende trotzdem gleich
dahinter mit einer gott mich jetzt hier
in dietingen geschichten rein geraten
wobei es natürlich der sinn der team
runde ist dass man auch gegen teams
kämpft beziehungsweise selbst team darf
okay ich bin konzentriert er macht
eigentlich nichts was irgendwie qualität
hat mitsamt traum aber ich bin nicht
mehr was einmal probiert noch eine
probiert noch ist relativ kurz aber ich
bin natürlich auch wie soll es bei mir
anders sein vor spät dran aber ich will
mich noch nicht so leicht geschlagen
geben vielleicht schaffe ich das noch
ihren zu gehen also derart gut ist war
alles wird am ende durch überlebt also
war es nicht nicht unglück so zu kämpfen
aber dieses mangels vermisst halten nur
noch eklig naja ok davon stecken typ und
ich habe vor allem ja ich wollte ja die
teen challenge ob ich teams besiegen
kann jetzt das gefühl alle sind besser
geworden im pvp und ich bin auf dem
gleichen stein verblieben
beziehungsweise habe mich nicht
verbessert
der öffentliche robert hau ab hau ab
mein feind könnt ihr den ausdruck mein
konto gehabt hatte den ich gold äpfel
oder hat er natürlich aufgehoben ich
weiß es nicht ich weiß es nicht ich weiß
es nicht ich weiß nicht weil ich ich
will eigentlich nur zu überleben oh mein
gott ich habe auch letztens eigentlich
festgestellt werden sagt noch sg
wirtschaftlich noch sg an
wie finde ich das gerade interessant ich
weiß nicht ob ich euch dafür begeistern
konnte
ich dachte ich hätte die gold ablauf
kommen ich glaube das war aber sein team
mit also der sich so unbeteiligt
dahinter gestellt damit dürfte ich
vielleicht ein team ausgeschaltet haben
kann aber auch sein dass das einfach nur
zufall war bisher in der hingestellt hat
man da anfangen wie spekuliert dass ich
nicht angreifen oder so oder verteidigt
was auch immer vielleicht einfach
weniger reden und mehr gewinn mehr
gewinnen besteht und vielleicht auch gar
nicht reden und einfach nur kämpfen tja
fragen über fragen in dieser heutigen
folge kam mir vor wie sie moderator aber
ich finde dass meine moderation skills
sich bei displays sehr im rahmen im
rahmen halten ein sehr begrenzt sind
ich glaube dass man irgendwo glaube hier
kam die explosion her
gott david reingehauen ein mal zu mal
schauen vielleicht hängt jetzt von
hinten können gott oh gott kämpfen alle
gegeneinander oder ok sie sorry für den
sport in chains heißt der hat natürlich
auch nur einmal getroffen
da kann ich jetzt glaub ich nicht so
viel machen aber ich kann mich erstmal
folge kunden großteil jetzt auch noch
davor sich keine brust freunde vor vor
diesem video fun fact hatte ich keine
brust hat er kaum schaden gemacht locken
macht so ein tier hinterher nichts
entscheiden hat man festgestellt
okay wir sind noch drei leute meine
chancen schätze ich die sonne ganz gut
ein und insgesamt bin ich auch zufrieden
mit dem verlauf dieses bündchens okay
aber vielleicht habe ich auch einfach
nur glück weil es gibt natürlich
wesentlich bessere spieler und ich würde
auch nicht behaupten dass ich besonders
gut wenn im vergleich mit manche anderem
der so mini kraft spielt ist es gewiss
zügig voran
nein er will teams in der 1
und da haben aber dieses wird dir nicht
gelegen mein feind wollte mein freund
sein oder er wollte einfach nur dass wir
alle kräfte
aber nicht mit mir schluss einfach
mitten rein
ich ziehe aus prinzip nicht an war jetzt
hat jemand weggeschlagen wenn ich jetzt
dann ziehen wir dann welche eine falsche
sei ja der wenn es die angel relativ
viel beziehungsweise gut hätte ich mir
auf jeden fall den linksrheinischen
können kann ich jetzt aber auch immer
noch wenn ich schnell hier in der küche
und dann kommt ach komm doch rein bisher
ich hasse das wenn man so klar dass der
sinn der angel diesmal auf distanz geht
aber ich hasse das es schreibt er
oder was macht er denn jetzt
ich habe kein gold ich dachte wir es auf
equipment keine ahnung ist mit ihm ist
okay du bist cool kämpft auch der hat
mich grad folge zogen ich weiß nicht
warum mir schau macht jetzt
wahrscheinlich hat er irgendwie gedacht
ja die stars youtuber oder so vielleicht
habe ich einfach nur warum macht ihr
denn jetzt faxen
darauf habe ich keinen bock
ist ja was so fordert deswegen nicht
geben aber eigentlich bin ich insgesamt
zufrieden das war ziemlich bossi gerade
und ich hoffe es hat euch trotzdem
gefallen und ihr seid nicht sauer dass
ich nicht mehr so gut wenn den pvp wie
es mal war
tschüss